[Music]
okay
so this is my review of episode four of
wanda vision we interrupt this program
so first off
i was mostly impressed with the first
three episodes the amount of detail put
into it the amount of effort put into it
how unique it is but i did feel like it
was struggling with the amount of main
plot they were pushing along
and only giving you a little bit each
episode to keep the story going forward
but that all changes here in this
episode this episode to me
was spectacular in so many different
ways i think it's the
best episode i could have just imagined
getting for an episode for after
what those first three episodes set up
and why this episode's so effective
is it sets out a lot of things for where
the season is gonna go now and get you
really now excited because you're now
actually realizing the protagonist of
this story actually isn't wanda
she actually is the antagonist in this
story
your protagonist is gonna be monica
rambo and what's so
awesome about this episode is it flips
perspective for you
because you're seeing everything that
happened in the beginning now from the
outsiders perspective
which i always think works and is really
effective and interesting but it also
really works because you see the
characters coming back and out from the
mcu of darcy lewis
jimmy wu is that those two characters
are
taking the role of the audience here
they're
just as confused as we are they're
trying to figure it out and it's perfect
to put
us in their place and really enjoy their
scenes even just seeing jimmy woo
trying to figure it out on the
whiteboard who everybody is it's exactly
what we're all doing him writing his
vision alive
yada yada it's the same stuff that
you're seeing in all the easter egg
videos
and what you're reading on reddit that
is what they're doing and it was smart
they made characters like that for us to
kind of
be in the driver's seat for us as an
audience now let me elaborate on what
i'm saying about
monochrombo being the protagonist and
wanda being the antagonist which i think
obviously makes this already something
mcu is so good at is just
doing something unique and creative in
their own universe
always changing things up and it shows
the again
amazing effects that infinity war and
the snap
had on the mcu and took it to the next
level where i started
really appreciating it for going into
different
places and now to show that they can
have
the reactions to people coming back from
the snap from all different areas
was so effective and especially in this
opening that played like a horror
sequence
with monica coming back we learned that
she was literally gone for five years
that her mother from captain marvel
maria rambo passed away
three years ago while she was gone
already for two years so
the effects of that it was just crazy to
see this hospital filling in they didn't
have enough room
but it already gets you to sympathize
with monica rambo and then
this episode plays out well with her
character to see how she got trapped
in wanda's world but it's also showing
you that
where she works the sword headquarters
and now they set up camp here
outside of this missing town of west
view is that
they're the ones we're with trying to
figure out what is
wanda doing and why it works so well to
have wanda play the antagonist role
right now is because it works so well
thematically with the grief she is
feeling about vision's death
and the denial she's in and not
accepting it and
making obviously this fake reality now
this sitcom world i saw
a great theory that the youtube channel
screen crush had
does great easter egg videos about the
show but him
saying that wanda's just creating
this sitcom world that she imagined of
just what a happy life in america is
like from growing up and watching it as
a kid
i know that was so fascinating and i'm
completely in that theory and believe it
that
wanda's created this false reality to
escape from what really happened to
vision
and i thought it was also interesting
that agnes the nosy neighbor played by
catherine hahn
i am so down to theory that she is also
a witch from the comics and was probably
someone that confided
in wanda when wanda was going through
this grief and led her down this path
and clearly wants wanted to have
children for some reason but with all
this great mystery the show's already
had you're already getting so many
payoffs here because you're getting
answers already you're getting
to see monaco is the one who sent in
that drone you're seeing the man who
came through the sewer and i love the
connection they had
with them watching on the tv and how
that came about and
bringing in that great humor with darcy
enjoying the sitcom i even loved the
line and she was like oh great monica's
got a speaking part now i thought that
was really good and her
and jimmy worked together comedically
really well and you really again got
that huge payoff from last week because
we got to see now wanda use her scarlet
witch powers
on monica and then get this flash of
vision when he was dead which was
really sad and worked really well and
you really felt for wanda here
but it gives you your motivation of why
she's doing clearly what she's doing
we're going to learn more about how
powerful wanda really is
remember she has all these connections
to the affinity stones she's done
something here where she's created this
world trap these people of this town
this whole town she has in a bubble
and it's just an awesome thing to see
and be
along this ride now and figuring out
what wanda is up to and what happened in
that time after vision died and you see
that's why they end with
monica here when she came out of the
bubble was like it's wanda it's
all wanda now i think that's exaggerated
for us as the audience to be like oh my
god wanda's behind all of it but i
clearly think there's other people
influencing her too to
make this bad choice of putting this
reality and not being in touch with the
world and making others suffer
i'm clearly leaning towards agnes here
the nosy neighbor
that she is a bad influence on wanda
because she probably is also a witch
like from the comics so we'll see though
and i thought it was also interesting
that this episode wu and darcy didn't
notice any of agnes in the footage they
were watching so they're clearly
keeping that at bay somewhere because
that probably would be paid off later on
more to her character they just don't
want to go there yet i thought this
episode was absolutely fantastic because
i think people who weren't digging the
first three
this is gonna draw those people back in
because it's really felt connected to
the mcu
it really was now easier to get and
really understand what's going on they
gave you enough answers to do that so
people who felt completely confused
at least got some more to chew on and
can kind of get their grounding where
they're at and having people to attach
to now
as our fellow audience like i said darcy
and jimmy wu
and now making you be like oh man like
wait a second
wanda really is now in this specific
story our antagonist so
how will they get the wanda we know and
love back
and get her to deal with her grief i
really love what they're doing here
i have to give props to kevin feige
because it shows the effect of having a
producer who's
overseeing all this stuff in the mcu but
he's a rare case where he actually still
cares and gives a hundred percent effort
to make sure
it all makes sense it's all smooth and
it has constant quality and that they're
doing something different
and they're doing it again here i love
it's in tv format because tv format is
my favorite as you know but to see the
mcu now take a stab at it
it's really exciting and so far i think
they're crushing it but for me
this episode is the best one yet clearly
9.8 i'm so excited for where this is
gonna go
i was on the edge of my seat this whole
episode and i love that it's based in
mystery and with a great theme of grief
with wanda
so let me know what you thought of it
down below i'd love to hear your
thoughts i read every comment try to
respond as many as i can
please make sure to subscribe i'll be
reviewing every episode of wanda vision
the day
they come out so you don't want to miss
any of those if you like what i do here
i really appreciate a two dollar monthly
donation i have a paypal link down below
that will help me cover more shows and
movies for you guys and i also do
celebrity interviews so
again it will give me what i need to do
this full time
and please follow me at steve varley
show on twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time